hello my name is Chaka I'm the group
editor-in-chief of Brutus are two media
holdings I just moderated a session on
state lat growth and talking about
responsible capitalism I think I was a
great consensus within both the panel as
well as the audience that the state has
an important role to play in economic
development the state has a social duty
and there are many areas of the economy
in which the private sector is unable to
provide the necessary services and which
is very state-owned companies come in
but it's also an understanding and an
awareness growing awareness now that
even state-owned companies must be
transparent they must have put copper
governance they must be in a certain way
profit-oriented even if they have a
larger social agenda to fulfill so the
state and the private sector in a fact
must coexist a private sector has a
right and has needs to space grow there
was one of the concerns it kicked he
kept coming back to being responsible
responsible capitalism in which both the
state and the private sector play
equally important roles thank you